pues en este vídeo quiero hablarles
acerca de las sucesiones y vamos a
estudiar los tipos de sucesiones
distintos que hay los primeros tipos de
sucesiones que hay son las sucesiones
finitas esto quiere decir que tenemos
una asociación cuyos términos son
finitos por ejemplo están 1 y después le
voy a sumar 3 me van a dar 4 después le
voy a sumar 3 y me van a dar 7 y después
voy a sumar 3 y me van a dar 10 tengo
esta sucesión que es finita porque si
nosotros observamos la cantidad de
términos que tiene es 4 que es un número
finito sin embargo también hay
sucesiones infinitas por ejemplo esta 3
ya es lo voy a sumar 4 3 47 y después
más 4 es 11 y después más 4 es 15 y
después para poner que esta sucesión
sigue hasta el infinito agregándose 4 y
4 y 44
lo que se pone son los puntos
suspensivos por lo tanto aquí tenemos
cuatro términos los cuatro primeros
términos de esta sucesión sin embargo
como en la sucesión es infinita se le
colocan unos puntos suspensivos y esto
quiere decir que es una asociación
infinita con una infinidad de términos
pues esta sucesión nunca termina
al infinito y más allá pues siempre
podemos seguir agregándole y agregándole
y agregándole 4 pero bueno ahora vamos a
fijarnos primero en esta sucesión las
sucesiones tienen varias formas de
escribirse y yo lo que quiero ver es
algunas notaciones de cómo se escriben
las sucesiones la primera anotación que
vamos a ver es esta de dos términos acá
desde acá igual a 1 hasta 4 y esta
expresión que tengo aquí nos da
exactamente esta misma expresión que yo
tengo acá lo que tengo escrito aquí es
una sucesión de forma compacta una
sucesión de cuatro términos este sería a
subíndice 1 es decir mi término 1 este
sería al subíndice 2 es decir mi término
2 aquí tengo a subíndice 3 es decir mi
término 3 y aquí a 4
aquí tenemos mis 4 términos de esta
sucesión que era finita los oscars desde
acá igual a 1 hasta 4 sin embargo si te
das cuenta esto puede hacer referencia a
muchas sucesiones por lo tanto sería
bueno especificar qué sucesión me da
estos cuatro términos y para eso se usa
la siguiente anotación lo que se suele
poner es lo siguiente
mismo en un principio a subíndice acá a
subíndice acá desde acá igual a 1 hasta
4 desde acá igual a 1 hasta 4 con y
después se pone la regla de asociación
es decir la función con a subíndice que
iguala y bueno como logramos una regla
de asociación que en un principio me dé
1 y después me dé 4 es decir lo que
hicimos fue aumentar le 3 después el
aumento de 13 me dio 7 y después del
2013 me dio 10 sería bueno de hecho
escribirlo para que lo vean bien que es
lo que está pasando de aquí acá hay tres
unidades de que acá le sumamos otras
tres unidades y de que cada otras tres
unidades le sumamos por lo tanto como se
escribe eso bueno lo que hay que hacer
es fijarnos en el término inicial es
decir a uno a uno es igual a 1 por lo
tanto acá va a empezar desde 1 entonces
se pone aquí uno más y después es algo
así como acá menos uno que multiplica a
tres caminos uno por tres de hecho
esperen tantito mejor lo voy a escribir
más
3 que multiplica acá menos 1 así se ve
mucho mejor a subíndice k es igual a uno
más tres por cada menos uno y vamos a
ver si funciona siempre es bueno que
esto sea lo primero que hay que revisar
vamos a revisar el primer término es
decir a uno en uno acá vale uno me
quedaría 1 menos 10 por 13 0 1 es uno en
el segundo término me quedaría dos menos
uno que es 1 por 33 más 14 el tercer
término me quedaría tres menos uno es 2
por 13 6 más uno es 7 y en el cuarto
término también funciona y es que esta
expresión que tengo aquí no es ni más ni
menos que una función de cab una función
que depende de acá acá existente en los
números naturales y recuerda así es
justo como se ven todas las funciones de
acá es igual a 1 + 3 porque a menos 1
una función que depende de campo ahora
vamos a fijarnos en nuestra sucesión
infinita como encontramos una expresión
equivalente pero en una sucesión
infinita pues bueno voy a poner que esta
es la sucesión de los oscars desde acá
igual a 1
pero esta vez como es infinita vamos a
tener un primer término un segundo
término un tercer término y así hasta el
infinito por lo tanto es desde acá igual
a 1 hasta el infinito y podemos dar
también su regla de sucesión en este
caso podríamos decir que tenemos la
sucesión acá desde acá igual a uno hasta
infinito con y vamos a encontrar la
regla de correspondencia a su vez acá es
igual a mi término inicial que es 3 lo
escribimos en un inicio más y después
vamos a fijarnos en cuánto es el paso
que damos estamos dando pasos de cuatro
en cuatro
aquí fue más cuatro aquí también es más
cuatro aquí también es más cuatro por lo
tanto va a ser tres más como el primer
término es tres hay que ponerle cuatro
que multiplica acá menos uno es decir
que siempre le vamos a quitar uno a
camps es decir al natural que nos toca y
por lo tanto la expresión de esta
sucesión o dicho de otra manera la
función a que depende de acá en este
caso es tres más cuatro por cada menos
uno ya estas formas de ver las
sucesiones se les conoce como
explicitan dejen ponerlo con un color
más llamativo la forma explícita o la
función explícita de esta sucesión sin
embargo también hay otra forma de
escribir una sucesión también las
podemos escribir de una forma recursiva
ojo no siempre toda sucesión tiene una
forma explícita de escribirse o una
forma recursiva de escribirse o muchas
veces puede tener su forma explícita de
escribirse pero no son formas de cursiva
o viceversa sin embargo estas sucesiones
que tenemos aquí curiosamente también
tienen su forma recursiva que vamos a
ver justo ahorita y vamos a ver cómo se
pueden escribir las cosas de forma
recursiva entonces tengo la sucesión de
acá desde acá igual a 1 hasta 4 con y en
esta ocasión para verlo de una forma
recursiva lo primero que hay que hacer
es definir el primer término aún no es
igual a 1 y después lo que vamos a hacer
es ir a ni dando términos es decir que
el término que estamos buscando va a
depender de los términos anteriores a él
el término canvas un no no no no mejor
déjenme ponerlo como el término cada
secas acá es igual al término anterior
es decir acá menos 1
a menos uno me estoy refiriendo al
término anterior de acá por lo tanto lo
voy a escribir aquí el término anterior
y después a esto le agregamos tres fue
justo así como definimos esta función le
sumamos tres le sumamos tres le sumamos
tres y por lo tanto lo que estoy
diciendo aquí es que a esta función
recursiva le estamos sumando tres al
término anterior por ejemplo si queremos
el segundo término va a ser el término
dos menos uno que es uno más tres pero
el término aún no es igual a 11 34 y por
lo tanto me da el término 2 si quisiera
por ejemplo el término 3 pues sería el
término 2 + 3 pero el término 12 437 iba
quedando perfecto el término 4 sería el
término 3 es decir 7 más 3 y es 10 y por
lo tanto ya tengo aquí su forma
recursiva esta es una forma recursiva
porque depende del término anterior es
decir los términos se van anidando y
ahora voy a hacer lo mismo para esta
sucesión de aquí abajo
tengo que acá desde acá igual a 1 este
infinito con la siguiente regla
recursiva mi primer término aún no es
igual a 3 y después yo lo que hacía para
sacar el término acá
me fijaba en el término anterior es
decir en el término k menos 1 y a esto
le agregaba 4 fíjense bien el término
inicial de estrés a 1 es 3 a 2 sería el
término anterior es decir a 14 pero aún
no es 347 el tercer término es lo mismo
que el término anterior que es el a 2
pero la 12 74 es 11 y entonces para
sacar cualquier término de esta sucesión
me fijo en el anterior y ya ese le sumó
4 y ya con esto logró mi función o mi
forma recursiva de esta sucesión
infinita que yo tengo aquí